good morning it's 656 I taxes in 30
minutes I have to do a little bit of
work so I'm heading over to the other
place today is the start of the second
day of the book I can't talk okay come
on we got a Harry
come on pecs run faster all right almost
forgot the camera
let's go so we're on the way yeah we're
going to I forgot to tell you I'm going
to Leeds for the book signing tour it
continues there I'll see you in Leeds in
like four or five hours there we go so
we are at a football stadium I slept all
the way this is so weird
I mean it's awesome but I haven't been
in a football field ever especially
we're putting you and go and to meet you
fans got a score a goal they got a score
goal I'm down for that
oh my god you guys are too sweet look at
all of this look at this cake it's
amazing it's a you can't see maybe it's
got a rainbow stuff inside very healthy
stuff icing got all kinds of Swedish
licorice but the deal is I got a sign
all of thee
so this is a very family-friendly good
note yes they're literally everywhere in
this stadium we're gonna have one big
brawl with fans and see who the last man
standing gets a signed copy of the book
all right we're starting now let's do
this more blood more blood Jesus
ah
okay you can't see me never again we've
done hey Alex we've done how many hours
three and a half hours three and a half
hours
how many of you I've left probably on
that okay it's doing well and we're just
taking a quick break okay
we did it how many hours was I hate old
eight hours oh my legs hurt oh that was
crazy
holy [ __ ] eight hour signing it's
supposed to be like four or two I think
three okay we did it leads to finish
tomorrow is Manchester I'm really
excited really fun birthday a lot of
people were like oh you did this on your
birthday but I had a blast so it's okay
now I I don't know what I will do I'm
traveling are we driving to Manchester
right now so I'll see you in my chest
all right it's 9:46 I'm in Manchester
now I just want to say quick thanks to
everyone for all the burbs they give
gifts I did get a lot of gifts and all
the birthday wishes I really did have a
great birthday so thank you I'm gonna
catch up because I'm in spoken to my
family or friends
they're probably wondering what the [ __ ]
I've been doing and I'll see you
tomorrow I'm going through all the
birthday wishes it's really fun to see
that's crazy how many people are just
like happy birthday I'm gonna sleep I'm
so tired
a little little bro Marie to be alone in
a hotel room but it's alright I you bros
support makes it worth it so I'll see
you bros tomorrow for another signing
yeah that's it that's
I'll see you tomorrow for another
signing yep that's it good morning I'm
in Manchester another signing early
today I I slept for like 12 hours
these signings are really rough man
because it's not like a concert I'll
just be doing what I'm doing for two
hours and then I'm done it's like it's
pretty intense but I'm excited I just
need to wake up a little bit I just
can't believe I have five more five more
signings to do I'm one hour late gotta
be a little bit of rock star right all
right
cool okay I finally me an effigy that's
all it is
from the forest with with Barbie heads
and it says looking fabulous this is all
the stuff I got from yesterday so each
of these books it's a person that I'm
gonna meet later with it's crazy so
people don't believe I actually think um
I don't know [ __ ] so here's the
evidence because I clearly signed four
or three of them again Oh God
oh so cold last signing in UK a little
sad but also very happy because the
brace
robbers yeah
we did 300 now we got I guess 900 more
no way something like that Ryan ranch
ooh
all right we done 700 300 left the last
one this is so cool
I never been able to say to him that
looks pretty anti-climatic for you guys
but it looks cool for me
so that's good all right we got to
finish this
we finished whoa no way we just did a
vlog anyway okay back to Brighton we're
driving back to Brighton we've been
driving like three or four hours so far
good stuff I can't wait to come home
with the pipes seven hours later we made
it back but we got all of this to unpack
this is all gifts from fans for my
birthday thank you so much oh my god
Hey Hey it's late - oh my god you're
crazy again I forgot to record an outro
good job parents it's just I'm so tired
after these events are really fun but
very exhausting it's like a what I said
it's not like a concert or I'll just
entertain everyone in like two hours I
really have to meet all the facts and
it's it's great but afterwards I'm done
I get two days in Brighton and then I am
off to New York San Francisco in LA not
sure how I will survive this insane trip
but hopefully I will thanks to everyone
who came to the event waited for hours I
mean you bros weighted equally long as I
did so I appreciate it thank you bro
kiss um I was gonna enjoy myself a
midnight snack and I realized that when
I was away for my birthday someone sent
me a cake and Martha didn't really say
too much she was just like it looks like
it looks like PlayStation and it does
but either way it's cake and I'm gonna
eat it and I just prepared a slice but
there is something inside the cake now
the question is do I just keep eating
coz it's literally just me I want to see
what's inside
cut it up in a way that will not damage
the cake let's do this it was a
controller inside so cool and it says 26
on it
that's so sweet I don't know whose idea
but that's so nice thank you uh it made
me really happy I didn't expect it so
that's really nice I love it
such a cool design I feel I feel really
honored
I love Playstation even more now but you
did it okay that was a little bonus I'll
see you in the next vlog as always stay
awesome
Oh No